tiens donc maintenant nous passons à
l'interview par amour on les bombarde
quand la bouche ça pendant le génial
bien michel larqué est ce que par amour
vous pourriez refusé un rôle
oui oui ah oui est-ce que par amour vous
pourriez vous convertir à une autre
religion que la vôtre si je comprends
pourquoi c'est important pour lui oui
bien sûr michel vous que vous auriez
fait prêt à changer de religion paramo
lui nous chacun garde sa religion ouais
bon vous savez tout ça ça se ressemble
maintenant pousserait peu importe de
véhicules devront parallèlement le
royaume moi je vais devenir le pape de
lattes ou bien est-ce que par amour vous
auriez recours à la chirurgie esthétique
ah oui
si on regarde bizarrement je lis même
pas comme ça d'accord alors là ça
devient plus chaud est-ce que par amour
vous accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse
mais dire que des manques avec moi ouais
ouais ouais c'est vrai que j'ai envie ce
nom vous soyez d'accord mais faut pas
trop que je le sache et c'est à yahia et
c'est difficile a dit à la télé une
solution avant une solution est-ce que
par amour vous accepteriez de vivre à
trois avec la maîtresse est ce que par
amour
accepteront ils avaient tous les soirs
on voit des changes et non plus est-ce
que par accepterait de devenir son
esclave sexuelle en quoi parce que l'on
voit ce que parce que parce que le
savoir parce qu'il faut que ça me il
faut que ça me plaise
il faut lui faire plaisir une envie
d'une sphère sexuelle le pot attends tu
voulais mais oui mais oui mais je vais
dire le
je comprends pour garder toujours pas
mariée mois non ça veut dire beaucoup le
sexe non alors sept ans je réfléchis ya
donc s'il veut aider cela une esclave
sexuelle c'est qu'il ya des trucs qui
vont peut-être peut-être je n'aime pas
lui latina d'accord d'accord bon est-ce
que par aman vous accepteriez de prendre
20 kilos parce qu'il adore les rubans
dieu qui m'aime comme juste voilà je ne
veux plus changé est-ce que par aman
vous seriez prêt à faire cet enfant en
une fois en une fois oui est-ce que par
amour ou seriez prête à cacher le corps
de quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
non non ne po il l'a pas fait exprès
haye avait exprimé une dernière question
le pire est ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à arrêter de fumer ou vfas touch 1
si tu reprends le lendemain n'étant pas
se sont émus au coeur de la porte
septembre
jésus
abbas